Це вододіл не просто між двома берегами, а радше між двома різними світами.
Навпроти обійстя Анатолія Павлюка починається Придністров'я - самопроголошена республіка, не визнана жодною державою світу.
Територія, яку видно ось там - Придністров'я - проголосила свою незалежність від Молдови на початку 1990-х.
Вона розташувала в себе російську військову базу й постійно підтримувала тісні зв'язки з Росією.
У багатьох жителів прикордонних районів України є родичі в Придністров'ї.
Із початком повномасштабної війни Росії з Україною, підтримувати зв'язки стало складно - кордон закрили.
Взагалі раніше з Придністров'я всі їхали в Одесу, сюди. Зараз - ні, потоку людей уже немає.
На сусідньому ринку, який раніше обслуговував відвідувачів з іншого берега Кучурганського лиману, нині небагатолюдно.
Місцеві не надто воліють спілкуватися з журналістами.
Адже ніхто не знає, як тут може відгукнутися війна, розв'язана Росією, і яку роль у ній може зіграти Придністров'я.
Звісно, боїмося. Звісно, боїмося. Але сподіваємося… Що ніхто звідти сюди не зайде.
Це наслідки вибухів, які пролунали в так званій столиці Придністров'я - Тирасполі - 25 квітня.
Наступного дня невідомі підірвали радіоантени, які транслювали радіо РФ. У Кишиневі це викликало неабияке занепокоєння.
Придністровські спецслужби одразу звинуватили диверсантів з України.
У Києві ж давно припускали, що Росія може влаштувати такі провокації, аби дестабілізувати ситуацію.
Не виключається проведення армією Російської Федерації провокаційних дій в Придністровському регіоні Республіки Молдова
з метою звинувачення України в агресії проти сусідньої держави.
Згодом - ще один тривожний дзвінок.
Українська розвідка оприлюднила фото нібито екстреного випуску Придністровської газети, який планували видати на травневі свята.
Це нібито "вісник з майбутнього": у ньому йшлося, про криваві теракти, які вже сталися.
А також було звернення до Путіна - залучити армію самопроголошеної ПМР на боці Росії.
Для цього на території самої РФ відкриваються мобілізаційні пункти для набору добровольців воювати в армії Придністров'я.
Таким чином Кремль намагається легалізувати тисячі своїх військових, які здійснюватимуть провокації з території ПМР.
Отакий вигляд наразі має армія Придністров'я. Підтримує радянські традиції і марширує в унісон з Москвою.
У Придністров'ї давно базуються і російські війська. Вони підтримали сепаратистів після того, як регіон відколовся від Молдови.
Бої закінчилися мирним договором 1992 року. Але конфлікт насправді не вдалося вирішити, а росіяни - залишилися.
Нині регіон політично й економічно залежить від Росії. Більшість населення - російськомовні.
Придністров'я затиснуте між Молдовою і Україною. У Москві прямо заявляють, що російська армія має намір захопити Одесу й прикордонні території,
аби відкрити коридор до самопроголошеної республіки і з'єднатися з тамтешніми військами.
Українська розвідка наразі не бачить військової небезпеки з боку самого Придністров'я.
Адже ця територія фізично відрізана від РФ, пояснив очільник Головного управління розвідки Міноборони України в інтерв'ю ЗМІ.
За даними ГУР, в регіоні присутні не більше 300 реально боєздатних та вмотивованих російських військових.
Водночас у Києві не виключають подальших спроб Росії дестабілізувати ситуацію і в Придністров'ї, і в Молдові.
У Кишиневі ж визнають, що не мають боєздатної армії, аби дати відсіч. Але "готуються до песимістичних сценаріїв".
Згідно з висновками нашого аналізу, нещодавні інциденти були спровоковані структурами в самому регіоні, які прагнуть ескалації.
Але водночас ми чуємо погрози російських генералів про їхні плани вийти до Придністров'я і, звісно, такі заяви є безвідповідальними та тривожними.
На тлі таких занепокоєнь у Брюсселі вже пообіцяли надавати більше військової підтримки Молдові.
Експерти не виключають, що в разі успіху Росії в Україні, Молдова може стати наступною ціллю Москви. Адже апетити Кремля не згасають.
Путін позиціонує себе як… генія, керівника, який все вирішує. Насправді ж є місце і для боротьби за владу, і для суперечок.
Як наслідок - ми бачимо непослідовність і неузгодженість у діях Росії.
Як на мене, Молдова - це яскравий приклад.
Ми не знаємо, чи це застереження, чи "показуха", аби відволікти увагу від України:
мовляв, "ми не дуже успішно просуваємося в Україні, але погляньте - у Молдові ескалація".
Чи це відволікання уваги, чи створення надзвичайної ситуації в Придністров'ї для підготовки до наземного вторгнення -
побачимо, бо від Кремля надходять різні сигнали.
Тим часом з українського боку кордону, на березі лиману, що розмежовує Україну і Придністров'я, Анатолій будує власний бізнес - літній бар.
Війна і напруга в Придністров'ї зачепили і його родину. Дружина поїхала провідати батька на інший берег.
Кордон закрили, тож їй доведеться повертатися через Молдову.
У неї батько, 72 роки. І що, він там один. Тому просто про нього забути - теж не варіант. Тому сподіваємося, вона там не застрягне.
Анатолій планував відкрити свій бар влітку. Але поки триває війна, перспективи для бізнесу залишаються примарними.